Caption: so all the way from the USA sike and I
Caption: all right thank you for that warm
Caption: welcome my name is Jennifer Mars MIT and
Caption: during the next 45 minutes or so I want
Caption: to talk to you about AI perks and how we
Caption: can use artificial intelligence machine
Caption: learning and data science to be able to
Caption: solve hard problems that are facing our
Caption: world today so let's start was just like
Caption: two slides to talk about the s of grant
Caption: program and then I missed for the rest
Caption: of the time telling you about some
Caption: amazing uses of technology and machine
Caption: really specifically for how you can use
Caption: that to solve some really big challenges
Caption: that I was facing so let me just start
Caption: with the quick background on what gives
Caption: answer so why work on the as workers
Caption: team at Microsoft and Anna for Earth is
Caption: a grant program so back in December of
Caption: 2017
Caption: Brad Smith who is the president of
Caption: Microsoft at a kind of change conference
Caption: in Paris made a big announcement that
Caption: Microsoft was publicly committing 50
Caption: million US dollars over a took on a
Caption: five-year time frame to anyone doing
Caption: machine learning or data science work in
Caption: our four focus areas of agriculture
Caption: water climate change and biodiversity so
Caption: you can be on the screen behind that
Caption: obviously repeating really big
Caption: challenges in that area being able to
Caption: feed the world's growing population
Caption: that's rapidly approaching 10 billion
Caption: people on being able to provide clean
Caption: water to everyone and dealing almost
Caption: with the issues that was being around
Caption: flooding and drought and sancho and then
Caption: climate change obviously a very big
Caption: we're all following and then
Caption: biodiversity the fact that species are
Caption: going extinct and arrays also sometimes
Caption: what they should be and so that is the
Caption: great program and the reason I'm telling
Caption: you this is because Australia you guys
Caption: you are like this hub of biodiversity I
Caption: know to spend yesterday a trotta's
Caption: island and only goodness the water which
Caption: is a vulnerable aspects of vulnerable
Caption: species is just this amazing little
Caption: animal and so I would actually and of
Caption: course the Great Barrier Reef and all
Caption: this other stuff so you guys are just so
Caption: uniquely positioned to do amazing
Caption: research and work to healthier so if
Caption: anyone knows of people were using
Caption: machine learning data science who would
Caption: like to get in on some of this grant
Caption: money the worst thing is the kind of
Caption: money that goes suspect so I just know
Caption: anyone who's doing work in the space
Caption: apply for a grant get something for
Caption: frankly here wonderful what is with the
Caption: rest of the time talking about is of the
Caption: grant recipients that in our network
Caption: that who have done some amazing things
Caption: using machine learning to solve these
Caption: really hard problems I'm gonna try to be
Caption: really explicit about who did this work
Caption: I want to be really clear this is not
Caption: all of my work I'm not taking credit for
Caption: this some of this is my person research
Caption: some of this is some of her print
Caption: recipient outside with my yourself so
Caption: I'll be really clear try to call out for
Caption: each of these stories who is doing what
Caption: the first one I want to talk about is a
Caption: project called project premonition
Caption: anybody heard of that already cut record
Caption: initial couple people's so project
Caption: premonition is something that was came
Caption: out of Microsoft Research and the idea
Caption: behind it is how we stop outbreaks of
Caption: disease before they happen so you guys
Caption: remember the Zika virus incident right
Caption: and then we kind of what's Nile disease
Caption: that's how Wolford
Caption: avian flu I suppose have these really
Caption: big infectious diseases that and create
Caption: these big public scares and so the
Caption: research madness whatever we did ahead
Caption: of those and predicted before they come
Caption: and so the idea they came up with is
Caption: what if we leverage little data
Caption: collectors that are out in the
Caption: environment already collecting random
Caption: blood samples and those are mosquitoes
Caption: right they're already taking blood
Caption: samples from humans from animals that
Caption: these diseases are coming from and if we
Caption: have if we're able to capture a mosquito
Caption: that's consumed a blood meal we can
Caption: actually use our genomics pipeline to
Caption: reverse-engineer from the DNA of that
Caption: flood and be able to tell what host
Caption: animal that died on and what diseases
Caption: they carry so that's we're gonna talk
Caption: about first
Caption: alright so this is actually just exact
Caption: 75% of these infectious diseases so that
Caption: how beautifully like those things that
Caption: you hear about Zika do originate in ear
Caption: holes
Caption: so they started animals are so then they
Caption: sprites and humans just 75% so a fairly
Caption: significant so we can catch those either
Caption: stolen animals before they kind of form
Caption: outbreaks that's a really good thing and
Caption: so I already kind of mentioned exactly
Caption: the process but these needles were going
Caption: around biting animals and we can collect
Caption: them or attach to them that we can make
Caption: a difference to be able to actually grab
Caption: that one to be able to be awareness
Caption: there's so there's really two okay so
Caption: the way this is actually dying is two
Caption: keys
Caption: research I want to talk about each of
Caption: those so one of them is an intelligent
Caption: track so I'll show you a picture in just
Caption: a second we have a smart tracks and it
Caption: can just collect you can it has a little
Caption: classifier too many classifier on the
Caption: device so it will only capture the
Caption: insects that we care about so we'll talk
Caption: about that in just a second it's
Caption: essentially a cylinder that's about that
Caption: maybe this wide around and it's got a
Caption: little little hole in the center and
Caption: then you can stick a lure in the hole
Caption: and because everything is a couple of
Caption: different types of lures we've used
Caption: light because insects return to the
Caption: light co2 because we exhale carbon
Caption: dioxide and insects love to are
Caption: attracted right to that only see some
Caption: sense of rightness of things and then
Caption: there's actually an hour on the outside
Caption: of 64 individual little cells and each
Caption: one of them have its it's a little
Caption: trapdoor and so what happens is an
Caption: insect can fly in check out the lure and
Caption: then fly away and within seven
Caption: milliseconds it will actually make a
Caption: decision of is this the kind of insects
Caption: we want to trap and then if it is we
Caption: will close that door and catch it and
Caption: it's actually really interesting I
Caption: didn't know predators work but the
Caption: treatment use you know that carries West
Caption: Nile does actually different than this
Caption: you know that carry Zika virus
Caption: so Zika virus is carried by a mosquito
Caption: called by the species ABC chip diet and
Caption: then on the West Nile is actually by the
Caption: Jewish Jesus so we can actually
Caption: differentiate between those two skills
Caption: like nine
Caption: as an actress so it's very very very
Caption: good so you can track just what you want
Caption: we move on test-fitting the riotous
Caption: things and that there's an accuracy
Caption: right there so let's dive into this to
Caption: research controversial so the first of
Caption: the smart tracker and a little look at
Caption: that left-hand side so you can see and
Caption: that could in lights as a lure in the
Caption: middle you can see attempt looks like a
Caption: circular apartment building almost where
Caption: there's all the little individual
Caption: windows and each one of those has a
Caption: little trapdoor and then once the trap
Caption: door closes it doesn't kill the insect
Caption: or anything they're just trapped in
Caption: there and so it's it's in there and were
Caption: able to capture it and be able to then
Caption: use it to study about what edit area so
Caption: very great it's worth specifically blood
Caption: feeding enzymes the second key
Caption: contribution of this work is once you
Caption: have the skills you need to be able to
Caption: actually drive interesting information
Caption: with them and so that's where our
Caption: metagenomics pipeline comes in so we can
Caption: utilize that blood meal that was
Caption: consumed take that concentrated DNA and
Caption: be able to run that through a DNA
Caption: sequencer and then be able to tell what
Caption: the host animal that fed off of as well
Caption: as diseases that were carried and to
Caption: what was interesting how we can get down
Caption: to that level
Caption: thanks buddy you're perfect go on and
Caption: eat it too engine on you this is
Caption: something that activist was so pretty we
Caption: can't manage what we can't measure right
Caption: and what is so crazy to me about this
Caption: whole thing since I started diving into
Caption: this research what is that we know how
Caption: with the species that are on earth right
Caption: now
Caption: Randy and so if we're trying to manage
Caption: like this biodiversity and these species
Caption: going extinct like how could we think
Caption: about you know with engineers this is
Caption: driving you crazy
Caption: that's that you even have a good
Caption: catalogue what exists now like how are
Caption: we supposed to track that well that's
Caption: one that really makes me crazy if you
Caption: look at the numbers up here dress my
Caption: word grace so those are land-dwelling
Caption: tresco art supplies those are such a big
Caption: bug there's an S can attend to the six
Caption: species but we really took all of them
Caption: and the bacteria knows there's an
Caption: estimated tens of the six to ten to the
Caption: die
Caption: species of bacteria viruses and if I
Caption: explain narrow that down to just viruses
Caption: per second you guys know how many named
Caption: virus is actually exist right now
Caption: viruses are things 4,500 insane will
Caption: have mates with 4,500 viruses so it's
Caption: just there's so much to learn there's so
Caption: much that we can do here okay so here is
Caption: a look this is using its the right
Caption: camera so it shows you the the little
Caption: traffic actress if you watch that Center
Caption: cell right there so just keep watching
Caption: that Center self units day but it'll
Caption: insect there's a lure in the middle that
Caption: since we're kind of hoping around and
Caption: then I've actually come to the sever one
Caption: there is there is and it closed you see
Caption: so that's exactly how it works is it
Caption: goes in it was actually happening there
Caption: under the covers is that there's a small
Caption: LED beam right there and then add it
Caption: passes through it's basically taking
Caption: time series data of imagine are like
Caption: have us a single pixel light beam
Caption: tightness and so that as it moves
Caption: through its gathering that data so it
Caption: can sense almost like
Caption: ladies is what it's it's measuring there
Caption: so as things go in we can use that data
Caption: that time series data that's cooking off
Caption: of that that little sensor to be able to
Caption: tell what kind of executives and then
Caption: the other thing that's kind of cool
Caption: about this is because they are trapped
Caption: and you can use this you could utilize
Caption: that in there that's an example of one
Caption: of the mosquitoes that was actually
Caption: caught using on this trap in Houston
Caption: Texas in one of our field sites with
Caption: Houston was had under the gazebo
Caption: concerns and if you are an entomologist
Caption: and if you study bugs would be so
Caption: excited about that because that mosquito
Caption: is it like pristine condition right the
Caption: state of your bug traps they are right
Caption: now use actually both super to use like
Caption: suction or fans so a lot of times by the
Caption: time the book gets through the section
Caption: of sand it's all like crazy looking it's
Caption: good it's not going to makes a good
Caption: sample and so right you're all those
Caption: little group it traps it so you have
Caption: this nice not they simple to use so very
Caption: very cool stuff here all right
Caption: um the main point I want to make on this
Caption: slide is the fact that this is a really
Caption: great example of using machine learning
Caption: on edge we obviously are mosquitoes
Caption: aren't as great as your quads that will
Caption: close for selfies in a wonderful way but
Caption: misuse our just like they're in they're
Caption: out there in big overly care and if
Caption: you're like so
Caption: up to the cloud waiting for response and
Caption: all that or you may or may not have
Caption: network connectivity you can tell this
Caption: is actually a really remote area and um
Caption: it's really weird you could tell think
Caption: you have cell phone coverage that the
Caption: woman isn't talking on her cell phone so
Caption: you have some footage with the Wi-Fi
Caption: it's a little sketchy whew this is a
Caption: pretty remote village which is only
Caption: actually accessible by boat oh wait on
Caption: our to sit there and so you can get a
Caption: sense for this is a minute really looks
Caption: better when you don't have to depend on
Caption: an internet and just stick it somewhere
Caption: and then be able to utilize the machine
Caption: learning right on the device so it is
Caption: all that ml is happening right on device
Caption: and it does happen within seven
Caption: milliseconds the other one I get is just
Caption: the relative size you could kind of see
Caption: what it looks like right there it's not
Caption: about 200 tripods so you can see it
Caption: there right in the context of the
Caption: village and all right so let's talk a
Caption: little bit more about the data that were
Caption: collecting here so I have three little
Caption: friends that reflected right here and I
Caption: already mentioned I was an accuracy of
Caption: about a three percent accuracy at
Caption: separating West Nile mosquitoes from the
Caption: zero speedos and these particular guys
Caption: the one on the left is by taxi flight
Caption: and they are known to carry African
Caption: sleeping sickness the middle guy is
Caption: scared you know who is a violent eater
Caption: as well as an agricultural cast and then
Caption: the guy on the right very rare breed of
Caption: mosquito that we actually found doing
Caption: work with on Jake got off of work that
Caption: she does with eat all day with the chips
Caption: this is one of the guy there's feeding
Caption: opportunity and there so a lot of a lot
Caption: of Google information and if you take a
Caption: look at these each of these charts so
Caption: the first turn that exceed the that's
Caption: the time series data that's coming
Caption: that little LED so as they fly into and
Caption: check out the more like I can see the
Caption: different tribesmen you can see they
Caption: each one of those looks distinct so
Caption: essentially different maybe patterns and
Caption: how they slide creates a different data
Caption: signature that allows us to
Caption: differentiate between these insects and
Caption: then the chart below that is actually
Caption: the same thing of that that same kind of
Caption: beam deep data only incentive in the
Caption: trying to mean it's in the frequency
Caption: domain so it's just an FFT of the data
Caption: bucket and then the little dots there to
Caption: show you which of the 64 cells it flew
Caption: into if it's that matters and then
Caption: there's a whole bunch of other data that
Caption: is listed below which is other stuff
Caption: that we collect every time an insect
Caption: rose so essentially every time an insect
Caption: flies and flies out even if we don't
Caption: catch it we can collect a bunch of data
Caption: about encounter so we might even just
Caption: choose to say like baby duck is it's
Caption: something like something that's not a
Caption: bloodsucker where it's like useful to
Caption: catch it and obviously what you can also
Caption: just monitor the insect population in an
Caption: area and see what kind of insects are
Caption: our present and such and then adds it
Caption: and these Pro happens it captures things
Caption: like lettuce you thought it to you or
Caption: that if they want to do at the time a
Caption: whole bunch of weather take elements so
Caption: very much pressure light wind other
Caption: things you can better provide the
Caption: sensors on there and have it just
Caption: capture all that data
Caption: and so that actually gives us a lot of
Caption: good information about kind of the
Caption: presence of what these insects when
Caption: they're most active that sort of thing
Caption: so this is actual data that we took that
Caption: was useful from the fund infusions
Caption: he actually had a honey Houston during
Caption: the secon traders and what's kind of
Caption: interesting about this is this is charts
Caption: that show for two three IDs in mosquito
Caption: so the one in the turquoise is the ABC
Caption: chip die so that's their thirty bucks
Caption: and then the one in the orangish is a
Caption: Hewlett's miss you know which is the one
Caption: that carries West Nile and so people
Caption: have all kinds of questions about like
Caption: in which would be you know everyone was
Caption: many bucks crazy crazy at that point but
Caption: like what was interesting it in the
Caption: Harris County the Department of Public
Caption: Health actually worked really closely
Caption: with us on this and they were amazing to
Caption: work with but this actually was able to
Caption: give them like the most precise like
Caption: down to the minute look how these was
Caption: usable behaving because I think they're
Caption: you know prior to that everything like
Caption: some general advice released about like
Caption: oh the mosquitoes are most active at
Caption: this time of day you know Dave versus
Caption: magnet evening ones versus the morning
Caption: ones but with this data we actually got
Caption: a minute-by-minute who is kind of what
Caption: these behaviors look like you can see
Caption: some interesting things if you look at
Caption: this one in particular you can see that
Caption: it doesn't affect that she looks with
Caption: either that much of that that's that
Caption: particular one is tracking barometric
Caption: pressure and you can see absolutely no
Caption: effect Felix is kind of does not care
Caption: about their interpreter but there's a
Caption: huge it very much is affecting behavior
Caption: and how active how many how many of
Caption: Egypt dynasties were out there and those
Caption: with the Zika carriers and so with that
Caption: data we can actually go and public
Caption: health officials could spray in the best
Caption: times to make sure that they were
Caption: killing
Caption: most accurately those in a time when
Caption: they were at the right place all right
Caption: okay so that's kind of the physicals
Caption: track all the cool stuff that we can do
Caption: there
Caption: however it's some point you need to get
Caption: beyond the physical characteristics as
Caption: you know and kids out to the genomics
Caption: level to be able to understand what
Caption: exactly is happening in what animal you
Caption: know what diseases are actually
Caption: happening here and so what we do is we
Caption: take the mosquitoes that are caught in
Caption: the traps and because you have so bloody
Caption: mosquitoes over there and essentially
Caption: turn them into mosquito juice
Caption: so they are very concentrated in the DNA
Caption: of the mosquito and then what we're
Caption: trying to do as fast as possible is take
Caption: that DNA sample so that comes out of
Caption: them and put it into a gene sequencer
Caption: and then basically were mask matching it
Caption: against this huge you know public
Caption: database of all partial a sequence life
Caption: forms in the Tree of Life which is crazy
Caption: as fast as possible we're trying to come
Caption: up with an output that looks something
Caption: like this so a computed recipe of you
Caption: know what is this DNA profile and it's
Caption: going to be so mix of here's like what
Caption: example 90% egypt i which is the
Caption: mosquito around this room was about five
Caption: percent Homo sapiens of five percent
Caption: didn't even before it was capture and
Caption: they finally very small perfect was this
Caption: novel rabid virus before you panicked
Caption: remember only 4500 viruses have names so
Caption: it doesn't in calculators discover
Caption: that's actually not that scary it's just
Caption: done okay and February sections to the
Caption: babies day okay
Caption: was carrying something akin to rabies so
Caption: that's what we think was right so
Caption: basically it's kind of a hard thing
Caption: right it's almost like imagine that you
Caption: can walk to the to the bar or a pump or
Caption: a tavern or whatever you say here and
Caption: you can be really tasty drink with your
Caption: friends right and you're like this is
Caption: really good because you don't know any
Caption: of the dancers drink things because you
Caption: spent university and the library like a
Caption: good girl like a stimulus is pretty good
Caption: I'm gonna make it work juice and then is
Caption: that you're trying to deconstruct that
Caption: as fast as I can
Caption: essentially that's what our Secret
Caption: Service doing is trying to given this
Caption: what are the little ingredients that
Caption: made them we do that as fast as possible
Caption: it what makes it possible to do that so
Caption: quickly it's you take on the over the
Caption: cold snap and this was developed in
Caption: conjunction between Microsoft Research
Caption: and UC Berkeley University of California
Caption: Berkeley and it is a free algorithm that
Caption: allows you to come to like this much
Caption: faster and using some they don't and it
Caption: does take things but essentially we are
Caption: able to run this and these numbers are
Caption: even better than this but essentially
Caption: something is complex as a genome there
Caption: this that's a very big big data problem
Caption: and so perfect for cloud right exactly
Caption: the kind of thing you want to toddler so
Caption: you can throw that analysis of an azure
Caption: we give them to run around like 250
Caption: notes or more or less and then we do it
Caption: idiots respond within a couple of hours
Caption: and so this was really really cool
Caption: because with the cloud airship took a
Caption: process that used to take used to take
Caption: like 30 days
Caption: something to sequence like one thing and
Caption: now we've got that down to like a matter
Caption: of hours so it's really really exciting
Caption: to see what could be done and then some
Caption: machine learning that's happening here
Caption: absolutely using Bayesian mixture models
Caption: and so what that does is you couldn't
Caption: see this okay but essentially there's a
Caption: cup there's a lot of similarities in the
Caption: Tree of Life all right so imagine like a
Caption: rat and a box oh how does the DNA is
Caption: very very similar than some of it is
Caption: different and so what this does is these
Caption: niche models allow you to be able to
Caption: essentially boost the signal of the
Caption: correct thing by looking it
Caption: probabilistically what's more likely and
Caption: that kind of dampens the signal of of
Caption: the things that aren't correct so helps
Caption: you be more effective there and you can
Caption: see how can you measure this probably
Caption: your next question right so we have a
Caption: couple things right here so if we up to
Caption: a complete synthetic test we can achieve
Caption: 90 like right now my accuracy so what
Caption: that means is we take so like here
Caption: Sestito DNA and randomly sample from
Caption: those genomes and then we take so some
Caption: host animal or human or whatever and
Caption: randomly sample some of that and then
Caption: randomly sampled from a some viruses and
Caption: mix that all together and throw it there
Caption: they can predict with 99.9% accuracy
Caption: count us and then if we could same thing
Caption: only in second life we incorporate not
Caption: all viruses so we take some places to
Caption: these unnamed ones in it okay here
Caption: something looks a little different how
Caption: well it did not do precise of a train on
Caption: that type of data and we still get
Caption: around 97% accuracy for that one and
Caption: then finally we do actual lab tasks as
Caption: well or means eveness you know real
Caption: blood
Caption: the real process knowing what that data
Caption: is and you can see chapters in there is
Caption: good as well alright so if you would
Caption: like any more information about this you
Caption: can feel free to check out the Microsoft
Caption: research page that is the lead
Caption: researcher even Jack steps right there
Caption: and it's Microsoft that comments like
Caption: premonition so that story number one
Caption: next let's talk about something called
Caption: farming meat sitting in their farm eats
Caption: this is an open microsoft research in
Caption: agriculture space all right so today is
Caption: how can we help enable it and feed the
Caption: world's growing population so in the end
Caption: of the United Nations in 2009 it was
Caption: actually stated that we need to double
Caption: our current rate of production if we're
Caption: going to be able to keep up with the
Caption: tomato so it's kind of the growing
Caption: population so we used to the right 2016
Caption: 8 2015 3 to double our current food
Caption: production rate and so how do we do not
Caption: like who could we use technology to
Caption: enable farmers and coastal health with
Caption: more data to the farming and so that was
Caption: the intent behind our peas and the
Caption: principal research runs are so they get
Caption: this is another Microsoft Research one
Caption: and the principal research on this one
Caption: is a gentleman named Randhir Chandra and
Caption: so when I joined the anti-terrorist team
Caption: I was you know really excited about this
Caption: one they're talking around here about it
Caption: and asking a ton of questions and the
Caption: really what they're trying to enable
Caption: some legal precision agriculture and so
Caption: if you're not familiar position
Caption: agriculture ok I think that is so
Caption: precision agriculture is the become for
Caption: a long time and within if there's a lot
Caption: of things like decision irrigation on
Caption: precision
Caption: pesticides decision you know light
Caption: distribution to the amount of each
Caption: levels all those kind of things and so
Caption: what that means is instead of the same
Caption: precision irrigation because of the
Caption: principle example
Caption: instead of homogeneously water in a
Caption: field with big sprinklers like usually
Caption: done today I said it's giving as refer
Caption: to feel the exact same amount of water
Caption: instead only water the amounts the field
Caption: that really needs it right because this
Caption: little dating people tips in the land
Caption: and water runs down on it and they do
Caption: disperse water more than this part so
Caption: you can actually use that to be able to
Caption: save it in reducing conserve the amounts
Caption: of water and the transportation of the
Caption: water called that the other thing
Caption: although I like the thought that my
Caption: sleep I'd like the precision agriculture
Caption: wanna get some precision pesticides you
Caption: guys cuz that's like a win-win all the
Caption: way around because the pesticides are
Caption: great for the environment they're not
Caption: great for us we're eating the food and
Caption: it's actually not made for the farmer to
Caption: be spraying a ton of those designs every
Caption: there because that's a really expensive
Caption: right so instead what they can do is
Caption: actually just spray pesticides where
Caption: pests are going to be and then if you
Caption: learning to predict that great and then
Caption: you're using a fewer about our less of
Caption: that which is a win we win all barrels
Caption: into precision agriculture so if we were
Caption: to tackle something at precision
Caption: irrigation that seems fairly
Caption: straightforward right any people do like
Caption: IOT right so you can have like a subset
Caption: sitting in their backpack right now that
Caption: they're properly measured water levels
Caption: and the guy the moisture one that I
Caption: played this before and so great they
Caption: seemed somebody to talk with us we just
Caption: sensors in the ground would be to
Caption: monitor things like pH level and water
Caption: and stuff like that and so what I'm
Caption: getting super excited up with something
Caption: I'm talking to Randy and maybe there's
Caption: something that's fresh problems actually
Caption: that it's costing about a thousand
Caption: dollars per sensor and that's so crazy
Caption: to you guys because that's one didn't
Caption: wake you have like no no maybe you're
Caption: not looking at the same website I'm like
Caption: have you ever heard of comment rather of
Caption: course he was aware in the problem is
Caption: not actually the cost of the sensor
Caption: itself
Caption: sensors are really in the tens of
Caption: dollars so what could be causing that
Caption: that money and pasta like some magazines
Caption: well the next thing it has power right
Caption: maybe you know these things are at farm
Caption: so is it the idea of so can we you know
Caption: how do you charge them right how many
Caption: those things charge and it turns out I
Caption: was wrong about that once it wasn't the
Caption: powder we actually do solar panels and
Caption: the solar panels cost roughly like 50 to
Caption: 100 US dollars for a solar count so
Caption: again we're talking like hundred now per
Caption: sensor that we're still not gonna
Caption: thousand and just kind of see a tangent
Caption: perfectly this is what our setup looks
Caption: like you can see the the board really
Caption: cheap although there's a low competition
Caption: that actually gives it include
Caption: waterproof casing and then there's some
Caption: leaves that stand out and it's about to
Caption: be comes at the base of that pole which
Caption: has a solar panel on top it charges
Caption: everything and then you very illusive
Caption: leaves sneaking out but you can bury the
Caption: leaves in the ground to like measure the
Caption: temperature at different depths or a on
Caption: water levels and all kinds of things I
Caption: don't do for ducks and we also have a
Caption: camera mounted on the science
Caption: so that they could get a real-time view
Caption: of the farm and it takes pictures in RGB
Caption: natural color as well as infrared so you
Caption: get a nice kind of T determine to look
Caption: at your farm as well with it different
Caption: places all over the farm okay so maybe
Caption: it's like $200 percent right so where is
Caption: the rest of this money coming from
Caption: turns out the problem was connectivity
Caption: all right it was getting the data off of
Caption: those sensors and into the cloud we did
Caption: aggravated and actually do something
Caption: useful with it and so the reason for
Caption: that is we think about a large of the
Caption: Pepa
Caption: if you've ever been doing a very rural
Caption: area and let's say if you guys are
Caption: making women across Australia has her
Caption: cell phone signal there you get great
Caption: coverage all the way across I'm guessing
Caption: no and from the looks of them
Caption: so what same thing the Ohio rural areas
Caption: those healthy carriers are at such
Caption: ability to provide and it very sparsely
Caption: populated areas and a lot of farmland
Caption: tends to be more sparsely populated area
Caption: so cell phone coverage is typically not
Caption: great so a lot of times if you have to
Caption: do this you have to layer up a custom
Caption: cellular solution which tends to be very
Caption: expensive so that's really where the
Caption: thousand dollars per sensor is coming so
Caption: so they'll tell you there's one option
Caption: another things Wi-Fi and Wi-Fi is the
Caption: great technology but the only problem is
Caption: it doesn't it doesn't stretch very far
Caption: right like I have a my child's bus stops
Caption: literally right across the street from
Caption: my house right
Caption: however when I like you know leave by my
Caption: office and walk across the street to
Caption: pick her up from the bus stop literally
Caption: a lot of Wi-Fi range like just across
Caption: the street from my house I can't even
Caption: reach my home Wi-Fi so
Caption: Wi-Fi you need so many computers they're
Caption: talking about these acres and acres of
Caption: farmland you need so many reviews
Caption: so two solutions to this solution number
Caption: one is can we use fewer sensors and then
Caption: be able to extrapolate that data to
Caption: learn more from from lives essentially
Caption: into essentially what we're doing is
Caption: we're coupling doing fewer sensors and
Caption: then we're coupling that with aerial
Caption: imagery overhead and primarily we use
Caption: drones for that and there's actually
Caption: some really cool I'd love to get into
Caption: the job work too because they're doing
Caption: all kinds of battery optimizations that
Caption: are really neat but the drone to ask me
Caption: about that later on your mark but
Caption: there's essentially the drones fly
Caption: overhead they take the aerial imagery
Caption: and then the machine learning model
Caption: takes that aerial imagery from drone
Caption: footage or so if some cases where
Caption: there's fall out of regulations and
Caption: drones are not a feasible solution
Caption: they'll use a essentially a big helium
Caption: balloon and tether it to the ground with
Caption: the camera and then the camera I like
Caption: make silicon and cannot take pictures of
Caption: all of that and either walk with it on a
Caption: lead or just planted somewhere as it's
Caption: not big enough so we take that aerial
Caption: imagery from usually drones sometimes
Caption: the balloons and then take that from the
Caption: data with the sensors that we do have
Caption: you can feed those both into a machine
Caption: learning model and then that is able to
Caption: predict the information that we can ask
Caption: and so those machine learning models are
Caption: actually based on Gaussian processes and
Caption: it's essentially conceptually you can
Caption: think about other but it is easy to keep
Caption: mixed what is the spatial similarity
Caption: right so things
Caption: farmland that tends to be close together
Caption: tends to have similar values usually the
Caption: other conceptual thing is visual
Caption: similarity so if I have a dark patch of
Caption: land right here on a dark patch
Caption: here maybe they were both freshly he
Caption: repeated and have similar moisture
Caption: levels and that tends to work as well so
Caption: those allow you to construct a machine
Caption: learning Maps to figure out like that
Caption: moisture levels of an entire field even
Caption: if you don't have sensors on the whole
Caption: field all right
Caption: so putting that all together that
Caption: enables all kinds of cool things if you
Caption: have all this data coming in off your
Caption: barbecue enable on precision irrigation
Caption: where to best do fertilizer applications
Caption: predicting yield all kinds of stuff you
Caption: can do with this great kind of temporal
Caption: spatial avanti of the farm now this one
Caption: other solution I want to mention because
Caption: we you know we talked about how how do
Caption: we get to stay off the farm and the
Caption: connectivity challenges that sort of
Caption: thing
Caption: so reducing the number of sensors we
Caption: have as women solutions that there at
Caption: Richmond is the second one and we still
Caption: need to get the data through sensors we
Caption: do have into the cloud right so what
Caption: just looked answered that connectivity
Caption: challenge and so this is actually really
Caption: cool
Caption: they're pioneering the use of something
Caption: called television white spaces so the
Caption: idea behind this is traditional Wi-Fi
Caption: operates at approximately five leaders
Caption: all right and so that's awesome but we
Caption: think about something like a TV
Caption: broadcast or a television broadcast
Caption: that's operating at a much lower
Caption: frequency if you're remembering science
Caption: you know what's lower frequencies you
Caption: know the way from stretch much further
Caption: right much much longer
Caption: and so the idea is to actually turn only
Caption: used television cameras so these are
Caption: likely we call these television white
Caption: spaces so basically frequencies where
Caption: these are faint broadcast on television
Caption: spectrum just to create an Internet to
Caption: send data packets over unused television
Caption: stations they can't just do this you
Caption: have to work the local government and
Caption: ensure that this is okay but you can
Caption: actually start
Caption: I lived this in Kenya and we think at
Caption: doing this and like alcohol about urban
Caption: areas as well just to enable like a
Caption: whole city with with Internet and that
Caption: sort of thing so that's do PMI
Caption: television white-spaces and so what's
Caption: really cool about this is that one
Caption: television likewise these router just
Caption: broadcast so far so imagine like you
Caption: live like 16 kilometres away you can
Caption: still access your home internet from
Caption: here like how cool would that be right
Caption: so really really neat out there one
Caption: television whitespace router can usually
Caption: service you know eat those acres of
Caption: farmland so a nice and nice solution
Caption: that Robert pioneering that's worked
Caption: quite well all right so all that's
Caption: happened about a bunch of pilot cities
Caption: going on and there's kind of the overall
Caption: architecture that I talked about so that
Caption: is farming also that Microsoft Research
Caption: all right the next time I want something
Caption: close to spot so spot is a systemic
Caption: motion detection the problem we're
Caption: trying to solve here is the poaching is
Caption: a very very very real concern and so
Caption: here's our Balam from NPR and if you
Caption: kind of zoom in on this video the date
Caption: is September 3rd 2017 all right so this
Caption: was within the last year so this is not
Caption: something that used to happen there but
Caption: I think this is still very much a real
Caption: problem today and just to kind of talk
Caption: about how why this is such a problem
Caption: here's a quick look at one of these
Caption: wildlife sanctuaries these these animals
Caption: we talk about rhinos and elephants and
Caption: some of these large animals that our
Caption: coach since there are such big animals
Caption: they have a very wide range of
Caption: where they were they wrong and so when
Caption: you consider the problem of Omega this
Caption: we have all over a limited resource of
Caption: Park Rangers thanks so much space like
Caption: how do we best predict where the
Caption: butchers are going to be bring the
Caption: animals are going to be and make sure
Caption: they can get out in front of it so
Caption: poaching is a is a huge industry I know
Caption: people are like that wouldn't even do
Caption: this that's so crazy but when you look
Caption: at kind of the economy here sisters why
Caption: this is happening
Caption: the average per-capita income economy so
Caption: Saharan Africa is about seven hundred
Caption: and sixty two dollars if you look at the
Caption: amount of money enough for a single
Caption: apartment right no more it's literally
Caption: worth more than gold of in terms of it
Caption: per pound and same thing with the ivory
Caption: is that far but it's still a one-person
Caption: elephant will give you basically a
Caption: lifetime's worth of income so this is a
Caption: very real issue and state of the art
Caption: right now how we fight it is drones
Caption: flying overhead and the drones are
Caption: sending back streaming data in real time
Caption: and that there are treatments sitting at
Caption: screens that have to monitor the drones
Caption: and have to look and recognize okay
Caption: here is the here is the this is use the
Caption: data coming in this is really hard for a
Caption: number of reasons number one you can't
Caption: scale well right it's a few more drones
Caption: when you put more drones in the air who
Caption: have to have more Cubans watching the
Caption: screens moment only so many screens look
Caption: out and then a lot of
Caption: at night so a lot of types of people
Caption: that are monitoring that they have to
Caption: work overnight and fatigue is a real
Caption: thing
Caption: so the implement that is this seems like
Caption: a great thing for provision right how do
Caption: we do how do we take by using computer
Caption: vision to solve that problem that will
Caption: scale and computers don't get tired so
Caption: the problem is it's just a harder
Caption: problem it's very hard computer vision
Caption: problems right number of reasons so
Caption: number one we're the fitter just coming
Caption: back with infrared footage so infrared
Caption: looks something like like that so that's
Caption: kind of what we're looking at here is
Caption: this gray and black and white blobs and
Caption: the first thing is actually the original
Caption: image then we have unfresh cooling right
Caption: there where it's popping things that are
Caption: above a certain threshold it makes them
Caption: later and then it also doesn't work to
Caption: stabilize for frame differences and
Caption: what's what that means is the drone is
Caption: moving overhead as well as sometimes the
Caption: animals are moving below but we have
Caption: animals moving that's actually been
Caption: indicator that it's now but I need to do
Caption: some work to do some fun math to just
Caption: make sure that when one thing is moving
Caption: another thing is moving you can
Caption: calculate that all that okay all right
Caption: but this is very very hard because first
Caption: of all the drones putting on the height
Caption: of the drones and where they can fly it
Caption: can get very very slick but it could be
Caption: like a you know a couple pixels of where
Caption: the actual animals is in them in there
Caption: and the motion that motion of the
Caption: stabilization actually makes it tricky
Caption: too and one thing that's moving and a
Caption: second thing is moving as well and then
Caption: just the fact that these are kind of
Caption: thermal infrared images like it's hard I
Caption: mean do you guys see it's right there in
Caption: out of the boxes and the less so that's
Caption: the
Caption: real folk jerison because I sure didn't
Caption: I don't have that expertise so it's
Caption: really hard to pick out real butchers
Caption: I'm in his situation so it's a tough
Caption: problem but a bunch of researchers that
Caption: this is work that's being done at home
Caption: by the University of Southern California
Caption: and their research they're actually
Caption: using Azure to be able to do some of
Caption: this processing so they basically if
Caption: they have a stable internet connection
Caption: to the data center real time to a like a
Caption: GPU laptop that they have they're on in
Caption: the field and then if if they have good
Caption: Wi-Fi connection they'll set it up to
Caption: address for processing and they trade
Caption: the models there and then otherwise
Caption: they'll just use the actual laptop to do
Caption: to get results because this is something
Caption: that also has to be difficult time
Caption: because once the poacher shoots the
Caption: animal it's game over
Caption: you can't undo that so it has to be done
Caption: about footsy as well so that's here's a
Caption: quick video that shows that one of a
Caption: field tests that they did and you can
Caption: see that when I had the little boxes
Caption: surrounded it's accurately recognizes
Caption: the people and so they are running and
Caption: we're almost there thank you mate
Caption: all right one one one other story is
Caption: some people I guess so this is one I
Caption: would love to see catch on in Australia
Caption: so I am sure this is a group that is
Caption: nonprofits this is another not Microsoft
Caption: story and they basically collect data
Caption: there's a little app that allows you to
Caption: take a picture of any flora or fauna and
Caption: then it takes that image it wants you to
Caption: label it so it's a labels data set which
Caption: is awesome and then give me the time and
Caption: the location of the observation and then
Caption: uploads there and then they take that
Caption: they said they make it publicly
Caption: available to researchers and
Caption: conservation biologists and all these
Caption: people to have this great index and what
Caption: so it's like a crowdsourced version of
Caption: that so that is my naturalism which is
Caption: there it's a big thriving community a
Caption: lot of people use it but why but the
Caption: reason I wanted mention she specifically
Caption: is that we've actually trained the model
Caption: based on the natural estate up and then
Caption: I was working with some researchers at
Caption: unnatural University who are trying to
Caption: recognize these specific and we were I
Caption: trying to use this and I hope to trying
Caption: to use the one that we trade on that
Caption: data and it totally didn't work because
Caption: people like financials is really popular
Caption: in North America so there's a huge North
Caption: American bias to the data that's
Caption: currently there and human says crazy
Caption: bees here man so if your piece look very
Caption: different than our little team bees so
Caption: if it wasn't performing almost I would
Caption: love to get more people like tell your
Caption: friends download it I use this all the
Caption: time and I need you watch with my kids
Caption: oh it's true yeah you know there's no
Caption: people where either I was the first one
Caption: that came to mind because I saw one
Caption: yesterday so those little things
Caption: I know Birds I don't know anything but
Caption: my kids actually just grabbed this one
Caption: for me now I want to learn what this is
Caption: and like they love it because if you see
Caption: a crazy squirrel or little animals or
Caption: any plants you can learn and actually
Caption: see what they are using the classifier
Caption: so it takes this step out to provide a
Caption: label one that just has been a picture
Caption: of her but one thing I thought what kind
Caption: of bird it is so how can I provide with
Caption: labels data if I don't know what kind of
Caption: art it is into a machine learning so we
Caption: trained a classifier on a bunch of you
Caption: literally existent and then use that
Caption: classifier that when you actually use
Caption: the app you can click something called
Caption: view suggestions and then if you
Caption: machine learning classifiers which uses
Caption: the image of the picture that you chunk
Caption: so it's using computer vision plus if we
Caption: use data on the actual location and feed
Caption: those together to make it available so
Caption: that's what's happening right there and
Caption: then just to jump to the example let me
Caption: just make it look good so this is a
Caption: picture I took in Stockholm and so
Caption: here's what it looks like when you put
Caption: it in the app it asks what did you see
Caption: you actually open it will grab this
Caption: right from the camera if you take the
Caption: picture right in the app and give you
Caption: the location the date time and then if
Caption: you took that what did you see you two
Caption: suggestions if you don't know what it is
Caption: it invokes this PC search and you can
Caption: see here I'm annoyed you with that bird
Caption: because I was guessing maybe Ukraine or
Caption: maybe a heron and it was able to tell me
Caption: yeah I'm pretty sure it's an errand and
Caption: then here's kind of the top tips easy
Caption: suggestions and if you click into each
Caption: one of these it actually shows you more
Caption: detail of the great herring and you
Caption: herring it so I was able to correct and
Caption: say oh this one is nearby and it's the
Caption: it looks you cover like that so psyched
Caption: and then I was able to submit up and
Caption: make that available a lot for for the
Caption: world so really really quick look about
Caption: we did train something with that and
Caption: you're welcome to check that out if you
Caption: want and put a little demo but we took
Caption: the items as soon as I can freedom to
Caption: species possibly hdpi and if it's just
Caption: the 5,000 most popular animals and
Caption: trained antiproton along that so you can
Caption: actually go here and classify and see
Caption: how it works and this case you're
Caption: something that looks like it can tell I
Caption: can differentiate that this is a coyote
Caption: and it actually knew that as opposed to
Caption: wolf and a lot of other things
Caption: so happy to show that in more detail
Caption: later but I wanna be like us enough time
Caption: one last story I wanna show you is a
Caption: group called wild meat so what they're
Caption: trying to do is solve the problem with
Caption: apples happy right so there was a verbal
Caption: spritz with National Geographic we're
Caption: really rare mail found people went to
Caption: tag it in the process of tagging it
Caption: ending up tragically killing the animal
Caption: which was the opposite of what they
Caption: wanted to do because it was rare amazing
Caption: animals so what they said was you know
Caption: can we do better right you guys know
Caption: that as human beings we can uniquely
Caption: identifying fingerprints right when you
Caption: say does advanced fingerprints well the
Caption: same is true for zebras and their
Caption: strengths you guys may have heard that
Caption: right then seekers have unique strengths
Caption: hunters it's also true for large cats
Caption: and their spot patterns for giraffes in
Caption: the works and their necks all of these
Caption: types of things so what they can do is
Caption: actually take you like that and the
Caption: state bases thousands of animals and
Caption: then be able to uniquely do that and you
Caption: can identify this individual pound of
Caption: muscle the last thing I wanna say that
Caption: is so cool about this so that is a
Caption: really cool computer vision story right
Caption: really really cool they're able to make
Caption: take this data and do some aviation but
Caption: what it takes a story from good to great
Caption: if they actually augment their data
Caption: using social media all right so let's
Caption: say I explain one of the things whale
Caption: whales hurt that works they are uniquely
Caption: can identify whale sharks and so we
Caption: private random person I don't want to
Caption: Kim and I
Caption: video and I upload that to YouTube they
Caption: actually have an intelligent agent that
Caption: wakes up at 10 a.m. every night it
Caption: searches the web it uses an NLP you can
Caption: find things related to will sharks take
Caption: that video extract the keyframes and
Caption: then it's able to identify and match
Caption: those against its database and find even
Caption: more new whale sharks and then with that
Caption: data it gets us to make population
Caption: densities as well as track individual
Caption: migration patterns whales in social
Caption: media for like Instagram in your food
Caption: like I just think it's such a cool use
Caption: so that's kind of what the process looks
Caption: like and then they can use that there
Caption: and I'm happy to show you guys a demo
Caption: about later alright so we've covered a
Caption: lot of different things we see
Caption: mosquitoes agriculture poaching from us
Caption: first own species identification as well
Caption: as identify different kinds of animals
Caption: if you want to learn any more about this
Caption: research papers any of that there's a
Caption: ton of great links right there
Caption: and then don't forget to tell people
Caption: about the I first grant program as well
Caption: if you're doing any work on machine
Caption: learning because together hopefully we
Caption: could use machine learning and
Caption: technology to make a difference thank
Caption: you
Caption: [Applause]